[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hi everybody and welcome to the
evolution of Tamriel panel here at
QuakeCon 2019 thank you to everybody
who's joining us live here and everybody
at home who's watching on the Bethesda
twitch channel
I'm Gina Bruno I am one of the community
managers for the Elder Scrolls online
really excited to be here today and I am
des Coulson also on the community team
for ESL and we are excited to introduce
our studio director Matt fire and
creative director rich Lambert
[Applause]
hi
oh come on up guys for them there we go
thank you welcome to Dallas we love it
here it's always this is the best
community show of the year so yeah love
coming here every year so Matt you are
the studio director for Santa max online
studios what does that mean for anybody
who may not know Matt what does that
mean way so I am basically the head of
the studio I was the guy that Bethesda
hired to start sauce to create the Elder
Scrolls online back in the Stone Age I
think it was 12 years ago or something
so you know I've been day-to-day with
the Elder Scrolls online since then and
rich was one of my first hires was
there's fun story with that too oh but
spill the tea told it a lot but yeah as
the creative director I'm responsible
for basically everything that goes into
the game so I work with all the teams
make sure things run as smoothly as
possible and review a lot of content and
you started off as a Content lead right
or a dungeon lead maybe originally I was
hired as a producer that's right I'm
right into be the lead dungeon designer
and then moved to the lead content
designer and then I'm the creative
director so you've been around for a
very long time yes rich was actually a
Bethesda before Zhou started he was a
producer on oblivion way back in the day
so he was one of the people that I met
first when I when I went to Bethesda he
was a huge MMO fan so the fit seemed
obvious the rest is history
so today's panel for the next hour we're
gonna be discussing sort of the
evolution of the development of the
Elder Scrolls online over the years and
then we'll be talking about what the
rest of the year brings and going
through some of the performance
improvements that you talked about
earlier this year when we announced
elsewhere live on Twitch yeah we do have
some updates for those so to kick things
off the team started development on ESO
ten years ago back in 2007 over ten
years ago yeah
so I imagine games like this go through
some evolution as you're creating them
what are some of the things that changed
early on for eso yeah so to put it in
perspective when I we started when I
started at sauce oblivion had only been
out for a year and a half so fallout 3
hadn't yet launched like that that's how
long ago this was so for me the biggest
most interesting thing was when we
started development of ESO the game that
we were looking at as an Elder Scrolls
game was oblivion because of course this
was four years before Skyrim so that led
to some interesting things that I think
we'll talk about but but it was you know
it was a long time ago and the first
thing was setting up the team by finding
people with online game experience
making sure that we were working well
with the bgs team to come up with an
idea for how Tamriel was seven hundred
years before the other games and that
was basically the first couple of years
for for rich and I was just solving
those problems yeah and a lot of
structural things you know what the hell
engine are we gonna use we're gonna use
how are we gonna like it was a lot of
kind of ground-up work to to get to
where we are today I'm a tiny bit of
lore and Elder Scrolls to [ __ ]
disappearo and we had always worked
pretty closely with Bethesda - from the
very beginning yeah yeah I had my first
four months at the company I'd literally
sat with the bgs team and with with with
the main guys there Todd and Bruce
incurred just to really get an idea of
what the game was going to be and making
sure it fit in with their plans so that
was super important because that
relationship obviously is important to
us every day as we deal with different
parts of lore and we make sure the
timelines are consistent in characters
are right and like we just went to
elsewhere this year and that was the
first time had been in an Elder Scrolls
game since 1994 so there's a lot of
discussion over what it's Kijiji culture
or how much do we want to go into it and
so forth and dragons and drive and that
was a big one we ran with them really
closely to figure out you know how that
would fit into our timeline so in 2012 a
little game called Skyrim came out I
think a few of you have heard of it
that kind of changed everyone's
perspective on what an Elder Scrolls
game is so how did that affect the
development of the game that had already
been in development for a few years yeah
so it was it was a big moment for us
because they really changed the entire
world's perception of what an Elder
Scrolls game is again it was oblivion
before that and Skyrim just was such a
massive hit that we had to look at what
we were doing and making sure that it
matched what Skyrim did so we made a lot
of changes in a very short amount of
time to make sure that we had
first-person we had a ton a ton of other
things a compass I remember there was a
compass and that was really where we
decided to do the Fulvio yeah oh yeah I
do full video that was and yeah it was
it was a big moment of kind of resetting
a new direction for you so which which
before that was much more of an oblivion
ask traditional MMO when it came out on
the other side as a small toolbar
compass instead of a mini map
Fulvio Elder Scrolls game really and we
did that in about 18 months which was
crazy
I remember we brought in I forgot if it
was press or some early players and we
didn't even have first-person in yet and
they were like well this is cool but
it's kind of missing a little bit of
test feel and I didn't even come in
until close to beta that was our first
press event in 2012 or something and
that was yeah that was a big moment of
I'm saying hey this is cool it looks
great but we really want first person I
remember don't have any kind of a fun
story behind it - that might be another
story for another time project this
that's really cool getting everything
all the inspiration from Skyrim so when
you set out to define your vision of the
game and the defining systems did you
also know that you wanted to create a
game where you could expand on the world
map and if so like how did you how did
you go about deciding what you were
gonna add and when and that must have
been a big undertaking yeah I mean I
think our original goal was get to
launch
you know get to there see what the
reaction was we knew had a planned post
launch of what we wanted to work on but
we also knew that there would be
feedback when we launched and we wanted
to make sure we had time to address that
so when when ESO finally did launch in
2014 forthright mmm
what sort of challenges did the team
face and how did that sort of define eso
evolution well I mean obviously a lot of
you were there with us so people that we
got a lot of feedback and which was
actually super important every game like
this goes it goes through this phase we
launch with some bugs that we should not
have launched with the one that stopped
some players from progressing in quests
was the biggest one and there were way
too many bots but you know that those
are bug fixes and we got those out of
the way pretty quickly but it was more
the it felt too much on Rails it didn't
feel quite like an Elder Scrolls game it
didn't feel like Skyrim so we knew we
had to go in and really go through the
feedback and pick on the key elements
and address those before we launch on
console which was a year later yeah and
I think we also learned a lot as as a
team in terms of types of stories to
tell and how to tell them you know we
focused a lot for a launch of having
choices matter and really have this
massive impact and what we found and the
feedback we got from a lot of you all
was those were cool but they separated
us from our friends and so we couldn't
actually play together and that was one
of the core kind of fundamentals behind
in mmm oh yeah 2 minute developer deep
dive here but one of our huge goals was
to the player can change the world right
and but what that meant technically is
once you dealt with a situation like
bleak Rock Island which is the ebon
heart pack starting area right the the
covenant comes in and there's a battle
in town and then you defeat them and
then their covenants gone the problem
was if you had already done that you
were doing it with a friend you didn't
see the battle and you didn't see your
friend because you were separated out
into a separate area because we wanted
to give you the idea that you were
changing the world
and what that really meant was we were
separating you from your friends and and
it's interesting how design goals for
games like this can lead to situations
which you just have unforeseen
consequences so we and by we I mean rich
spent probably 14 straight weeks doing
nothing but removing that idea from most
of the POS in the game so that you could
then even if you had done something
before you could then take a friend
through it and and you would you would
still remain remain visible to each
other but still though I'm sure there
are places in the game where that still
happens because of that design decision
we made in like 2011 yeah and we just
found different ways to tell those
stories now it's not the world has
completely changed its this character
has a different name or a different
appearance or a different look and so
you're still in the same space as your
friends things they'll play together
you'll hear guards talking about things
that you did and only you hear that and
if you're if your friend or your group
maid hadn't done that they wouldn't hear
the guards saying that so we fed you
figured out ways to do it that were
pretty interesting but that was a big a
big big thing we had to do between PC
and console launch also interesting is
we had even even then we had kind of
three feedback mechanisms we had the
community which was super vocal and very
good with knowing and passionately what
yeah it was that was good but we also
had our you know the whole team was
playing the game and figured out pretty
quickly what needed to be done but it's
also interesting even though there
weren't like massive amounts of people
playing in the game we had a core group
of people to play the game every day
through launch through through console
launch and we looked at what they did
and tried to figure out kind of the
magic that they were seeing and we made
a lot of decisions based on the behavior
of that group of people which was which
was very important for us so after
launch was there a specific update that
you feel was instrumental to putting ESL
on the path that it is today oh yeah
that one's easy
I'd be update six right yeah so I was
back before we had names for updates
just a number so our goal of course was
to approach all of this feedback from
launch and get it all done before we
long
on console so console would launch and
the console players would kind of get
the benefit of having the year of
changes update six happen to be the
update right before console launch and
that was where basically everything
happened we dropped the required
subscription we put in new facial and
voice animations we streams up here on
the BOTS we changed combat to make it
much more kind of visceral we did a lot
we killed VR ranks and put the champion
system in there
I think VR was still in at that point
was it better than pretty sure it was I
think that was later in a difference
maybe it was yeah it was kind of a weird
calm yes but it was a lot of stuff and
and that hard work that we did over that
year led to ESO being a super massive
hit on console which is kind of when the
whole turnaround started but update six
is really really what led to that so we
have the original trailer that we showed
when up to eight six launched and we
just wanted to share that with you to
kind of take a look walk down memory
lane imagine it's 20 or early 2015 and
this is what the video we've used
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow that was a long time ago yeah we're
we're laughing here because we totally
forgot the justices when we were talking
about this and the dice take for granted
the only crafting rich Wow yeah so lots
of stuff there so fun to watch and yeah
we branded that that that version of the
game Tamriel unlimited which is why it
was called Tamriel limited but that was
really update six and the crown store
came in there and we dropped the
subscription and just on tons of stuff
so when did you switch over to the
quarterly update cadence for YES on why
was that such an important decision for
the team and the future of the game that
was pretty much right after console
launch right and one of the things that
we wanted to make sure of is we kind of
saw how players played the game where it
was kind of a cyclical thing where they
would come in they play really hard for
a while and then drop out for a bit and
then come back and so we wanted to make
sure that we had content for them to
come back to at a regular cadence and
that's kind of where we we fell in yeah
I mean we made the decision that we
wanted to keep people engaged in the
game after console launch I think we had
Imperial City which came out maybe that
was the first was a very first yeah and
then we had or seen iam already on in
the in the can because we had finished
it before console launch and so that
came out after that and then we'd had
two updates in in six months and we
figured that every quarter was a was a
pretty good cadence to keep people
interested in the game now our sin IAM
is an interesting one because that was
originally designed as just a regular
zone right and it had it went through
more than a lot of iteration so our sin
IAM that was with update 8 that included
things like gamepad mode was in there so
you could play with a controller if
you're on PC subtitles was a big one
that a lot of our community was
requesting so again we can wanted to
show everybody the trailer from Orsini
um launched they came out you four years
ago do ya know BAM
in 2050 a lot of works incoming is this
one of the outsiders who responded to my
invitation
welcome to Arsenio
my son needs someone at his side who has
nothing to prove
I am Quran king of the or severe we will
rebuild or sit him make it stronger
whoever dares oppose the uniting of New
York clans will feel my wrath welcome to
my war
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I think the most long-lasting thing that
happened with or sinem was the one of
the first titles that came up which was
playable at any level because we had a
very long argument in the office as to
what level is or sinem because the ESO
was a level based game back then and it
was is it for end game players is it for
you know do we make it level 10 do we
make it level 30 and we decided that we
would use our PvP level scaling system
and apply it to our sin IAM so that
anyone could play it no matter what
level they were and it of course had
drastic ramifications because that was
what what ended up leading to one
Tamriel because people the feedback to
us was oh my god this this DLC is
awesome like the story is great which it
is but the best thing was I can play
with my friends no matter what level
they are and our guild can have guild
events there no matter what level they
are and we're like oh my god then you
kind of forget yeah that even used to be
a thing yeah we're levels and it's a
fairly new concept to us you know and
and really to the to the industry was
kind of that freedom to play with
anybody
yeah and so Orsini have turned into the
place where guilds could have events
because they could recruit members it
was it was it was great it was all
because we didn't know what level to
make it paper yeah and it was a really
great testbed for us well thanks for not
being able to make a decision
[Laughter]
so yeah the RCM storyline was great it
was considered by many to be one of the
biggest best story DLCs we've ever
released especially at the time it was
our first one so how did you guys decide
to move forward like and what what did
you decided to do next as far as DLCs
and based game and how did you make
those decisions with all of Tamriel to
choose from I mean I guess it's a lot of
Matt and I yelling at each other you had
a long list of things a lot wanted to do
lots of places to go but really it just
kind of comes down to looking at the map
I'm kind of where the map was and how
full it was
you know we tracked that very closely
and we watch and we look and it's really
cool watching it over the years where
you know this is what it was at launch
and then we added in these DLCs and then
out in the chapters and you can see the
map slowly filling in over the years
yeah but definitely right after worse
inium it was on our list and we got the
feedback from everyone that it's not an
Elder Scrolls game without deets Guild
and Dark Brotherhood so yeah those were
the next two DLC as we did him we knew
we were gonna do those I think even
before console launch just because the
game just didn't feel complete without
so that's that's where that led and then
after those two we released the first
dungeon pack that we ever did that was
shadows of the hist I had to look
because I talked to I crying to remember
all the dungeon facts is oh yeah we've
done a lot of those yes it's not easy
but then after all of those updates
there was still that kind of nagging
problem of how do I play with my friends
when there's still kind of that level of
separation yeah I totally scooped that
with the Orsini we all know kind of what
happens so what's in iam launched in
November octoly October early November
of 2015 when we came into the office at
the first workday of 2016 we always have
a have a the directors oh I have a
meeting of like what are we gonna do
this year and we made the decision that
day that we were gonna level scale the
whole world and so after a few holiday
weekend visits yeah I went over to his
place a few times yeah over the holidays
and we went back and forth and what is
level scaling here and how do we thought
it would what is level this mean what
what you know and that's yeah so while
we were working on Thieves Guild in Dark
Brotherhood
and shadows of a hiss we were also
working on one Tamriel at the same time
that's a pretty big undertaking I
imagine it was it was massive yeah it
was a huge amount of work and not just
looking at quests and kind of how they
interacted with things but looking at
the world and how the monster scaled
properly and how the players scaled
properly and how loot worked and it was
a huge huge undertaking and I don't like
looking back on it now I don't know how
we did it because it was so much work I
think it was like 9 months that we spent
working on yeah 1 Tamriel yeah I think
the the directive I gave the team was
in Grand Theft Auto you don't think
about what level the game is you just
jump in and play it like this game
should be like that just jump in and
play it don't worry about anything let
the game figure out how difficult it
should be and that led to every zone
needing to be redone a little bit
because each zone was essentially now a
little piece of the final game like the
whole game is the endgame right every
zone has a story some world bosses some
delve some dungeons so solo play
multiplayer or big group multiplayer and
we did that on purpose but that meant
rich and his team had to go to every
zone and make sure that there was the
whole game was encapsulated in each zone
so we have the original trailer that we
released with one Tamriel and remember
this was a free update too for everybody
because we wanted everyone to kind of
experience this so we wanted to show you
guys the original trailer from back then
it's pretty wordy because we getting
this concept across the people it's very
hard but here we go
the continent of Tamriel for years
divided by unnatural boundaries three
alliances walled off and isolated a land
of conflict and strife
but no longer a new era Dawn's in
Tamriel 1 without borders without limits
welcome to one Tamriel
[Music]
tamriel now your stupid school including
craglorn remade and renewed
[Music]
journey alone for food with other heroes
regardless of level
[Music]
prove your mettle by challenging friends
to a duel travel wherever you want
whenever you want
[Music]
prepare for adventure without limits
this is the Elder Scrolls online this is
one Tamriel
[Music]
that's it pumped so we know that the ESO
community is really great about
communicating certain features that they
want improvements they want to see in
the game and we're pretty good about
listening I think we really do try to
kind of implement a lot of the things
that the players say that they want so
one tamriel also had dueling in it which
was something that we hadn't had from
the beginning how how was that kind of
building in a dueling system where it's
essentially PvE in PVE pvp in PvE areas
this is something that our lead combat
in PvP designer Brian wheeler focused on
entirely you know working with the team
in coming up with the rule set behind it
and how it was gonna impact things like
the cities' and you know densely
populated areas and overall I think it
turned out fantastic you know there's
lots of really interesting places that
you can go and do a duel you definitely
know when a duel is started you know
that was one of the you know really
early on development discussions we had
is how do players know when they're
gonna you know the duel is actually
going to get started like and even now
to this day there's tons of people that
duel and they do all everywhere oh I see
it when I'm kind of passing by a major
city I'll see it on the outskirts like a
little crowd of people so yes exactly so
at this point now that we've kind of
released a lot of DLCs and updates we
had one Tamriel come out yeah so was a
lot more successful a lot more thriving
we had a very active community at that
point and I think internally we were
really proud with what we had
accomplished so we have one more video
to show you guys now this is one that we
kind of created for ourselves internally
yeah so this the first time this has
been shown publicly but it has a lot of
footage from other videos but but every
year we have a
a showcase at headquarters to show off
the kind of things we've been working on
and every project up with us it does
this and this video is the video that we
put together as a team to show the
company who was hard at work on lots of
lots of other things kind of what we've
been up to over the last year and it's
really summarized it summarizes it since
launch so you'll see thieves guild art
Brotherhood or sin IAM and it has
definitely not an Elder Scrolls
soundtrack because uh we wanted to make
it a little more hype than we usually do
for our videos but this is so this is an
internal video that we showed the team
to kind of celebrate leading up to one
Tamriel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so good it's funny I was kind of like
tapping my foot a little bit I'm like
wonder how many other people are and I
look over and you are doing so many good
comments you in our next update after
that introduced player housing to
everyone again for free employees people
created some crazy cool stuff in the
player housing even pay her to be here
it's ok Matt a few years ago we changed
up the DLC formula a bit and started
introducing the concept of chapters so
what was sort of the inspiration behind
that change Wow so the inspiration
behind it basically was one of the big
key things was a successful Moore's
inium and it showed that people really
wanted bigger moments you know wasn't
just a you know a theat skilled Dark
Brotherhood which were great but they
wanted new big areas to explore but with
our team the way it was structured we
couldn't do that in the way that we had
done or seen him because we did that
while we're working on on console and we
had a little bit more time so we had to
come up with a new cadence per year to
make the June update be and be a giant
one and that was kind of some team
reorganization and making sure it all
worked but I think with the with one
Tamriel it definitely led to a situation
where we could come out with a new thing
brand it with a name like more wind or
somerset and we could attract new
players to the game for it with it
because new players could come in and
play the new stuff and it's not like you
know there's Gen 1 MMO is where you have
to power level through 120 levels just
to play the new stuff right you can you
could just jump in and play it
immediately from the first moment and
believe it or not that's why we call
chapters instead of expansions because
and that came from me because when you
say expansion in this market you think
EverQuest Dark Age Camelot world
Warcraft right and it's in you need to
be a super high level and a hardcore
gamer just to get to be able to play the
new thing but so we call it a chapter
because we wanted to give players the
understanding that it's just another
part of the game that you can that you
can explore and have fun and once a year
in June yeah it's a good time to get in
and you know if you're fresh brand new
you can just jump in and play right away
and that's why we do a tutorial every
time because new players believe it or
not come in with with with with the with
the chapters they come in very regularly
in June we have lots of new players the
game even now like when else we're just
launched we have lots of new players
come just to play the new stuff in fact
we have a significant group of our
players that just come in and play the
chapters and then they go play other
games and then come in June and play the
new chapter that's fantastic I mean
that's it's a perfectly valid way to
play the game so as you guys mentioned
chapters were a pretty big game changer
for eso so can you walk us through the
transition from then until today and
even in the future and how to how it
kind of impacted the design for eso well
there's a logistical problem that we
have to solve there and the chapters
take a long time to make
you know usually about a year so we
can't have the entire team working on
one thing for an entire year so we have
to find ways to almost play leapfrog
with the teams and then the other side
of the coin is the types of stories we
want to tell and how they're all kind of
connected and you've kind of seen that
evolution over the years leading up to
elsewhere where you know if you look at
Somerset it was Somerset which was
focused on the elves there was some
werewolf stuff in there in between in a
dungeon pack I missed the first dungeon
DLC sorry Mike dragon dragon bones
that's right and team and then we
finished it with argonians so it was
kind of this hodgepodge of stories that
didn't really kind of connect to one
another and then we decided with
elsewhere that we wanted to tell this
year-long story that you know the entire
year was focused on that so that when
new players came in or returning players
came in they kind of knew what was going
on and where they could start if they
wanted to start or they could just jump
in and continue on the story as they see
fit
and that's where season of the Dragon
came from
was this is the first year we've done it
where all four content drops over the
year tell the same story essentially so
yes it has been hugely successful having
kind of one marketing tool like the CG
videos that you saw at e3 and on launch
like those all tell the same story the
same stories the player so it's been
really really successful for us so I
don't see a reason to change it yeah
there's a lot more cohesive yeah it is
and believe it or not it's actually
easier on the team because the art team
kind of knows for the entire year
whatever building the content team's
kind of know what they're building and
and so it's it's a lot easier in terms
of workflow so this we initially
announced that in January that we were
gonna do sort of the season of the
Dragon by the way do you guys remember
that rich was supposed to get his tattoo
like you guys can see it's still a work
in progress but it's not done yet that's
a lot of a 20 hours so far and I have a
few more hours to go to finish off the
back but it is in progress and being
worked on yes so this all started with
wrath stone and the beginning of the
year and then we just released elsewhere
which was the latest chapter part of
season of the Dragon and we have two
more updates after that so what is the
next one so the next one is scale
breaker which is a dungeon DLC pack you
can see some of this here on the screen
and the focus here is really on some new
interesting mechanics it's thematically
tied to the season because there's
dragons and you find a little bit more
about the dragon guard and kind of the
dragons in the world and then there's
also a really cool new prologue a quest
that comes along with this for the base
game that introduces a character that is
rather beloved I think in the in the
game incise aha and he comes back I'm
not gonna tell you how you'll have to
play through and figure out on your own
and then we have a bunch of quality life
improvements in here as well so you know
multi craft and multi guild trader
bidding and also I'm changing the
Andante keys to currency too that's
another big one the nice one
yeah so this update is actually on pts
now players are going through testing
giving a lot of feedback we will be
launching scale breaker August 12th for
a PC and Mac and August 27th for Xbox
one and PlayStation 4 so coming very
very soon so we're tying up the season
of the Dragon in q4 dragon hold but
there's more that the team is working on
so what are some of the upcoming quality
of life features that players can look
forward to Wow dragon hope oh I'm sorry
I'm getting ahead of myself
should we do dragon hold first a little
bit about dragon hold because we did say
that we were gonna be giving you a
little bit more information about this
yes so dragon hold is our q4 story DLC
it's similar in size and scope to Merc
Meyer or clockwork City the focus of the
storyline or the majority of the
storyline here is on the dragon guard
and kind of putting the band back
together let's notice be like you're
gonna learn a lot more about the dragon
guard kind of who they are what they're
all about why they're important to the
world of Tamriel
and then as just you know mentioned
earlier this is the culmination of this
season of the Dragon and so you're gonna
tie off all the loose ends so this is
footage from Dragon hold it's the first
time that we showed off any of this
footage before so it looks really nice I
think yeah uh-huh what's that was that
rich what are we seneschal yes the city
is censure so it isn't southern
elsewhere yes southern elsewhere you're
gonna get to explore a lot more of that
and kind of see a different type of
Cugini architecture we don't want to
spoil it too much but yes if you hadn't
played through elsewhere yet we can't
talk about this too much without
spoiling fast parts of that story
slipping to the end of the book yeah I
was trying to choose my words very
carefully
so we'll be talking a lot more about
dragon hold sort of as we get a little
bit closer after we release skill
breaker I keep wanting to say scale
caller like we did that I can't be the
only one that keeps doing so as just was
saying this isn't the only thing that
we're working on and we have
improvements to some quality of life
features and also to the activity finder
and this is something that we tested in
this current pts cycle with some players
we turned on some new code that we have
for matching players up in dungeons so
how how is all of that work going and
why can players sort of expect from it
when are we thinking that's gonna be
coming out etc etc so lfg in particular
is something that we basically rewrote
from the ground up so there were lots of
issues with it especially under load the
team went back reworked that entire
system we like you said we did the test
on pts it uncovered a few things we're
still working on that stuff and it will
go
ideally up in update 24 which is dragon
holds and then that kind of leads into
the other big thing that we're we're
working on a lot and we don't talk about
but is its performance and this is
something that the community has talked
to a lot you said hey you guys don't do
anything you're ignoring us no we're not
we're working on things a lot of the
things we're working on though are very
very long poles and so you can see some
of the things that we're working on
you know memory management is a big
thing and one of the things we're
working on with that is kind of how we
allocate memory and how we you know free
it and and request it and right now one
of the big issues we have is just how it
gets fragmented so like a hard drive you
copy a whole bunch of things all over
the place and the hard drive the old
hard drives got fragment and you have to
defrag it we're working on a system to
clean that up and make it better so
you're gonna see major improvement in
terms of stability less crashing less
dashboarding if you're on console yes
especially on lower spec machines oh
yeah like the base ps4 in the base Xbox
one yep that'll have a big a big quality
of life improvement
with that change you should see some
performance improvements with that as
well and then on top of that we're
looking at abilities and looking at
their impact on the server how they work
optimizing those we talked about the the
lfg system now the behind the scenes
combat ability of provements that's
completely different from the ability
audits that yes yeah this is more
looking at the abilities from a server
performance and client performance side
of things rather than do these numbers
math out correct yeah to the user it's
more when you're in a in a situation
where there's lots of combat going on in
PvP or in trials the server gets gets
gets under load way too much this is a
kind of one of our first step you notice
there's version two coming up later
later on so this is the first thing to
take care of some server optimizations
to make sure in combat that the server
isn't isn't too much under load and
stuttering yeah and so some team members
are working on those things but others
are also working on quarter ones next
year's updates the patching overhaul is
kind of the biggest one that we're
actively working on have been for quite
a long time and this touches pretty much
every file in the game Wow
yes it's a it's a big update and and
what we're doing is we're going through
and we're looking for a duplicate assets
old assets that are no longer needed now
that we do things better and smarter
we're removing a lot of that so that'll
free up a ton of space on your on your
hard drives
ashlee console yeah especially console
that will also reduce the overall sizes
of patches going forward once we do this
it does mean that when we do push this
out to live everybody's gonna have to
redownload the game while it repatched
is everything and gets it to the new
system but for the greater good yeah
once that happens the patching should be
a lot more streamlined and faster and
loading and loading into the game and
loading into new areas will be greatly
greatly improved after this yeah and
that's another part of this we're taking
the opportunity while we have to touch
all the assets anyway to update our
libraries you know our compression
libraries and that's going to like Matt
said significantly reduce load times
it's gonna make things load a little bit
faster you know
player those black silhouettes that you
see everywhere on you know in
high-traffic situations a lot of those
are gonna go away now because things
will load faster yes and we're gonna be
releasing I think this week post which
next next week this week sometime in the
next seven days we will be releasing a
update on the website which goes into
this in a lot more detail and kind of
who the the fixes are targeted at and
the expected user results so you know
we're taking this performance thing
seriously but when you dip into the guts
of the game that's been running for you
know five years it's been in development
for 12 we got to be really careful how
we do it in places so but this is we've
been working on a lot of these for
months and months now but we're more
more confident that that will start to
hit at the death of dates that we told
them when that article goes live we'll
also update that regularly you know I
think we're gonna try for at least once
a month you know and just give you a
status update of kind of where we're
going and what we're doing and as we
uncover new things you know some stuff
may change but that's you know what you
saw there is is what we're working on
and what we think is going to
dramatically impact performance of the
game and when you say performance what
does that mean because we'll see a lot
of people say like this is laggy which
can meet a lot of different things so
when you're talking about improving
performance yes what does that mean
bunch of different things but it's frame
rate it's server responsiveness it's
being disconnected and the client
crashing in some cases it's load times
it's it's all of those it's all of those
things anything as a group not working
under would everyone be glad to know we
are burning that system to the ground
and and rewrite and rewrote it
completely yeah that will be it'll be
much better off exciting can't wait to
start getting some of that out
so yeah queue for this year is kind of
the beginning of that yes many yes and
again like like Matt and rich said that
graphic that you guys saw that'll be
going up on the website sometime next
week with a full article kind of
detailing all of those things
and the timeline graphic will have a
social asset push for that as well every
month dated person it's just we're still
working on this just to kind of let you
guys in on how everything is going yeah
that maybe a few of them yep we're still
working on it but we're committed to
doing a monthly update even if it's that
so I think we have just a few more
minutes so one last question before we
wrap up one of the most common questions
we get and places like quick con online
is is it too late for me to hop into the
game I haven't played in a while I've
never played will I be behind what do
you guys have to say to that my answer
is no like now's the best time just jump
in you know play the game we have an
unbelievable community they are super
welcoming they go out of their way to
help and clearly true yeah they go out
of their way to teach new players how to
do things and the other thing I say is
yes there's a very different game it's
not a rush to end game you know it's the
experience of exploring and stories and
leveling your character up it's not just
get to the endgame get the loot in and
kind of get out and because of how a lot
of our systems work
you're never behind you can play with if
you're a max level player and I'm a
brand-new player coming in I can play
with you and we can make meaningful
progression and that completely changes
the dynamic of how you play the game you
really can't do anything you want is the
character called sleeps on bridges yes
he's not going in who will just appear
sleeping on bridges yep and that's what
he does yeah it's pretty apparent the
nautical I think it's pretty apparent
that we get better and better as
storytellers every every year you know
elsewhere was great Somerset was great
Merc Meyer was actually really good so
we're you know the stories just keep
getting better and better and now we
have such a wide breadth of area in the
world we can bring back characters that
you love we read your posts we know
which characters you love expect to see
you know
you know I don't want to spoil anything
but but we brought back sigh you know
and so it's just expect to see some
familiar faces oh you know forever as
well as we keep telling stories
hopefully forever yes any final words
before we wrap up I always say this but
I always mean it it's thank you so much
for making this game what it is because
seriously we've just gone over all this
stuff but it would make no difference if
you weren't playing it so thank you
everyone seriously absolutely I mean
that
mobile community who is watching online
as well yeah thank you to everybody who
tuned in online for everybody who came
today at QuakeCon thank you for joining
us and thank you guys for popping over
and chatting with us basically 12 years
in about 50 minutes a lot of ground to
cover
yes so thank you everybody and enjoy the
rest of your quakecon and we will see
you there
[Applause]